uh
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
so
good evening
welcome to the table
my name is kelly and
i'm so glad y'all are here
it is a beautiful day outside i'm loving
the temperature being dropped thank you
god for touching the thermostat and
lowering it some that's good that's good
news for all of us
um right after service tonight there's
going to be a state of the table meeting
which is just the coolest name and
someday we're going to have shirts if i
announce it that makes it real so
it would be cool
um it's just like getting into the nitty
gritty details of what's going on behind
the scenes transitions in leadership
about our meetup groups and just
touching base with everyone so if you
call the table you're home please join
and if you don't and you're just curious
about more of the nitty gritty details
because we
are very transparent we would love for
you to to join in
and
do that
as well please welcome our band to the
stage
[Applause]
um
yeah i don't know about y'all but i'm
just tired this week and maybe it's just
that we've been in school now for six
weeks so
one time i was in this yoga class and
they encouraged us to you know take a
deep breath in a collective sigh
and i just thought that sounds so nice
to do that collectively as a group so it
can be a sigh of relief a sigh of joy a
sigh of grief but if you just want to
close your eyes take a deep breath in
and just deep breath in and
that's good
thanks cal
are we on
check it check check check maybe a
little bit
i'm so glad that you guys are with us
tonight would you all stand to your feet
and we're just gonna spend some time
um
in this worship set and i just want to
invite you guys to um tap into the
creative side of your brain for a little
while because i just feel like we are
very stuck in the uh
the monotonous routines of life through
most of our week you know kind of like
almost forced to be
on schedule on time handling all the
practical to do's and music is one of
those gifts that gives us the
opportunity to sort of disconnect from
just the practical and
engage the other side of our brain
so um however that works for you i'm not
sure you know like for me there are
certain things that
help me kind of switch gears
but for you it may be just closing your
eyes for a minute you know and having
some presents as we start the music um
but whatever it looks like i just hope
that you'll take this space to shift
gears a little bit and see if god meets
you there in the shift
and uh and be open to to whatever
goodness he has for us together tonight
all right
gary's going to get us started
[Music]
do
my
is
[Music]
lay your burdens down
in oh fight
[Music]
the story isn't over
is
[Music]
check your shame at the
anymore
[Music]
help us
room
[Music]
is
now
[Music]
all right you kiddos are dismissed to
your classes and we'll see you after the
service
all right let's keep going
[Music]
jesus thank you for the way that you
invite us into your family
for the way that you've made space for
each one of us and our stories
and the way that you walk with us each
day
through the highs and lows
god you are present
and you are close
yeah we just want to
be with you we want to spend time with
you we want to experience your love
[Music]
thank you for being with us here in this
space
[Music]
for you have delivered me
sing that again
i
love you lord
for you have delivered my soul from
[Music]
i will walk in the land
sing i love you
i
love you lord
[Music]
my feet
living
[Music]
save
i will bless you lord for
[Music]
long as i may live
and i
love you lord
for you have delivered me
[Music]
i
will walk in the land
[Music]
will you guys join me in the prayers of
the people and if you're online with us
we invite you to join us as well by
leaving your requests in the comments
and we will share those aloud with the
room so that we can all participate in
this together
read this aloud with me please
god for this city of saxi texas and for
every city and community and all of
those who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick
for the widow and the orphan
for the injured
we pray to you
the poor and the oppressed
the unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and for all
who remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us
and that you hear us
and so we lift these names and
situations up to you
from online
pray for james's friend burke who had a
heart attack
[Music]
for brooklyn and isabella's families
oh
[Music]
for the names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace
and a deep sense of your presence
amen
yes
[Music]
together
the poor
rest we will dance forever
[Music]
behold
be
[Music]
he's
the sun
[Music]
the darkness
he's making
[Music]
he
we're not destroyed
we've seen
[Music]
we're not destroyed
we've
[Music]
my
eyes my eyes
[Music]
oh
making all things
[Music]
he's making all things
please
oh
[Music]
wow
thank you god
thank you for this time together jesus
thank you
for your constant
steady love
thank you that you are present in all
things
[Music]
and that you can take the most broken
tragedy
and somehow work
in us in such a way that we are able to
continue to love and continue to show up
and continue to trust
because you never leave us
you never forsake us
you are always there
so god even in the areas where it is
hard right now we open up our hands to
you and we trust that you are going to
be enough
that you will see us through whatever
we're facing
that your love
will remain
and it will hold us together
[Music]
god we need so much more of your love
we need it for the difficult
relationships that we're facing we need
it for the brokenness around us in this
world
we need it for our own despair or
depression
god fill us up
and tonight in this space would we be
able to walk away
trusting a little bit more believing a
little bit more
loving a little bit deeper
[Music]
thank you for who you are
thank you for being our rock and our
anchor
in the midst of the storm
god we keep looking to you guide us
it's in your name we pray
amen
before you guys sit down would you just
turn to the people around you and
welcome them make them feel at home
and then we will continue on with the
message
well
[Music]
good evening
grace and peace
my name is brett i'm the pastor here and
it's um really really good to be with
all of you
and as always that includes both those
joining us online love you lutz and
um and anyone here who's new maybe your
first second third time
just kind of you know feeling feeling
your way out i um or i should say in
hopefully in um you know i know it can
be um
just depending on church backgrounds it
can be really difficult to come into a
new space like this a it's just the
social element of sometimes you feel
like oh gosh these people i'm sure
they're all like best friends and
i'm not their best friend how's this
going to go you know
when the truth is you know you have
folks here here who have been here two
weeks and two months
and two years and you know it's sort of
at various levels but it's easy to
imagine everyone's like they're besties
you know um or depending on church
background there can be a lot of pain
and hurt associated with church you know
so then there's just all those fears i
know even coming into um a space like
this with like the crosses and the you
know the arched roof like just the even
the architecture of it can at times be a
little bit difficult um for folks if you
were maybe hurt in a in a church setting
you know it's interesting how spaces
like impact our minds kind of like smell
is like that too you know you smell
something it's like boom it just hits
you flood of memories you know for other
folks they walk through those doors and
it's like boom maybe it is even smell
like churches and old churches have you
know like a certain i don't know
mustiness you know i mean like there's
just something to it that just hits you
and it's like oh all the memories so i
don't know exactly everyone's story
where you're coming from but um i just
want you to know
that you are
wanted and welcome here in this place
jesus was i believe um just the most
hospitable person
uh to ever walk the face of this earth
and um and by that i don't just mean
like nice to people but i mean like
actively welcoming and expanding the
circle of care and welcome and so we
just we um we just really want to do our
best to embody and live that out so
anyway um i just want you to um just
know that so uh we are in part two of
our series right now uh titled unclean
drawing near in a runaway world
and um we're basing this series on a
book um by christian author and
psychologist richard beck titled also
unclean uh he has a different subtitle
but um it's it's really just a i mean
it's a marvelous marvelous book and my
my hope for the series is that we can
kind of see jesus again for the first
time so to speak
um
getting a fresh take on his life and
ministry and and what he was about so we
can like seek to live it out ourselves
um
now having said that so last week we
kind of introduced the series
many of you remember the first 12 or 13
minutes or so we're kind of gross
because we were talking about disgust
psychology
and uh it's basically that reaction we
all have to disgusting things you know
things that just kind of like we're just
uh whether it's a mold growing on food
or
rats or insects or i don't know whatever
it is you find just kind of revolting
and like
now kind of left just at the level as we
named last week
maybe discuss psychology wouldn't be
like some big deal that we need to talk
about in church the trick is
um that it's not just this was kind of
our big idea uh last week that
the danger of disgust is the way it kind
of influences or invades our moral
imaginations it is not merely things
that we come to view as unclean
uh it is people
and you might ask like how does that
happen
and the key word there would be moral
imaginations because this isn't only
about maybe external outward things that
someone um maybe we might find kind of
revolting or or really difficult about
someone whether it's you know they don't
smell good or something it's not just
that it's it's moral imaginations means
like um it's about their living
and um
disgust psychology it really pairs up
with the idea of sin
uh and we start to view people
who don't you know live the way we think
they should live or whatever um as like
unclean dirty impure
and
this can happen both where we view
others that way also we can be on the
receiving end of this where people start
living especially you know in a
christian context start living with a
lot of judgment um towards
us for some reason
um and so that's really what this series
is about is trying to kind of delve into
that unpack it
and
so tonight um
i
well i should mention one more thing um
that language part of the way this jumps
is moral metaphors you'll recall we
talked about this like we often speak in
metaphor when it comes to sin um
for example like if you say you know
that person is toxic
that's a really powerful metaphor very
punchy and like boom you know which is
different than saying that person's on
the wrong path
you know that doesn't have quite the
same
kind of grab yeah
you know what i mean um and part of the
is because what um disgust has to do is
it does a few things it well i won't
mention them all but the main one is it
alerts us to dangers of contamination
so you can imagine when that starts
entering into
people and all of a sudden i start to
think of people or a group of people or
a person as kind of unclean impure
will then to um use that kind of
language to use that metaphor of their
dirty
like you can see where whoo
that what's going on there well it's
triggering that disgust psychology in us
and we start fearing oh if i get around
them
then what might happen to me
maybe i'll get
unclean so
where i want to go tonight is um kind of
asking the question um
like why is this such a challenge um
particularly in church contexts in
religious
contexts so um with that in mind the
title of my message uh is
mercy and sacrifice
mercy and sacrifice we have a few
different scriptures tonight
and um you'll notice they all kind of
circle around a similar theme we'll
start with two readings from
shorter readings from some prophets and
then we're going to read the same
passage we actually read last week that
we're going to add a verse to it so um
we'll start with a reading this is from
amos chapter five
uh where amos speaking on behalf of god
says this verse 22
i will not accept your burnt offerings
and your grain offerings
i won't even notice all of your choice
peace offerings
away with your noisy hymns of praise i
will not listen to the music of your
harps instead what does god want to see
instead i want to see a mighty flood of
justice
an endless river
of righteous living
powerful powerful words you might hear
um echoes there dr martin luther king jr
loved that
that last line
another passage this is from jeremiah
chapter 6 verse 20
again speaking on behalf of god he says
i will not accept your burnt offerings
your sacrifices have no pleasing aroma
for me
so you can hear the connection there
right so different prophets different
times but they're echoing a similar
theme and of course this would have been
quite a shock to the original hearers
because based on certain old testament
passages like and we'll get more into
this they were commanded by god to offer
sacrifices so it's like well what do you
well what do you want from me i thought
i thought i was following your will
uh but suddenly
there's kind of some pushback coming on
this um finally we come to a passage
that we're revisiting like i mentioned
matthew chapter 9 verses 10 through 13.
a little little story here while jesus
was having dinner at matthew's house
many tax collectors and sinners came and
ate with him and his disciples
when the pharisees saw this they asked
his disciples
why does your teacher eat with tax
collectors and sinners in other words
with people that they see as unclean
on hearing this jesus said it is not the
healthy who need a doctor
but the sick
one thing to notice is the metaphor
switch
could you hear how they were operating
with a purity moral metaphor right even
though they didn't overtly say it but it
was sort of implied oh how could you eat
with those people
right what was what's the metaphor
they're using they're unclean impure
right and then what does he do he
switches it from one of purity
uh pure impure to sickness and
health it is not the healthy who need a
doctor
but the sick
verse 13 this is the line we're adding
but go
and learn what this means i desire mercy
not
sacrifice
for i desire mercy not sacrifice for i
have not come to call the righteous
but
sinners
so i desire mercy
not sacrifice jesus is quoting hosea
chapter 6 verse six um with this line
and um
in many ways you can hear they're
echoing those prophets we just read
earlier um
from jeremiah and amos
with their lines although it's a very
kind of succinct way to basically say
essentially the same thing um i desire
mercy not sacrifice um
what is the kind of question i want to
ask is um what exactly does that mean
um i mean jesus obviously he said we
need to learn it right he tells the
pharisees go and learn what this means
so presumably it's important
um
but i think this the question for us
would be like well what would that
actually mean for us in a day and age
where um he's kind of referencing here
you know plant and animal sacrifices and
we're like yeah don't really do that
so i'm not sure what exactly this would
mean i guess i'd just be merciful um but
i do think there's there's something um
in this for us so in order to kind of
understand um what he's getting at i
think we do need to understand sacrifice
now
from an old testament perspective this
was of course it's a very kind of rich
image um in in ritual though and it kind
of shifted meaning over time
um
but at least a key part of it and it's
for our purposes tonight a really key
part of the idea of sacrifice in the old
testament
is
that it was about the holiness
and the purity of the person offering
the sacrifice
in other words the idea of a sacrifice
is um
that well and this is something i think
we can relate to um have you ever
kind of done something
and um afterwards
you felt kind of like dirty
you know i mean like you felt like you
did wrong and you're just like uh
uh i don't even actually beck mentions i
think it's um i'm not big on shakespeare
i think i was even supposed to read
something about shakespeare in high
school and i just watched the movie and
uh if you know me i'm a reader i i tried
shakespeare but i was just like oh gosh
i hate this um so sorry if i'm offending
any shakespeare fans but i've heard so
becky mentions though um macbeth
and apparently macbeth um participated
in some sort of murder sorry if i'm ruin
it for you if you're gonna go in
um and afterwards it became kind of a
compulsive hand washer
and that's sort of the connection right
it's like you do this thing in the moral
realm and suddenly it's like i really
need to wash these hands up i don't know
maybe three or four times you know or
maybe you've done something and like
just felt the need to like i need to
take a shower here let's just it's
something where it's like we don't feel
good on the inside and so there's almost
this psychological need to like i need
to do something
to
get right you know to get clean too and
it's it's interesting the connection
again you see it between the kind of
inside of us and the outside um or maybe
even it's not like ritual you know
taking a shower or hand washing or
something but even if it's um just the
need to even confess
you know like you just you're carrying
something on the inside
and you just feel gross
and it's like i just need to
tell someone i need to get this off my
chest like i need to get right get my
soul right you know whatever language
you want to use but there's that right
this this need right are you guys kind
of some yeah so
um i think this is you know this is very
much something where you can relate to
even in like modern times you know of
course we um people don't tend to um go
to the the priest or the pastor as much
to like confess their sins anymore
but um in many ways modern day therapy
has sort of replaced that need i think
you know and um it's just we just keep
going on like needing to get things
out
you know
and and so in a way i think although
sacrifice and all that can feel very
remote from us like i can't relate to
that at all
really i think in a way even though we
don't do that thing anymore
the impulse i would say the the
sacrificial impulse
um is kind of there in us you know this
need to atone
this need to
be set right to be declared right maybe
that's even some of what's happening in
confession is the need not just to say
it but also to be absolved
in a way you know to
to be forgiven or to be restored to be
what is it made clean
right there's something like
in us um operating and happening
um
now
okay so as we um
so why does jesus kind of echoing hosea
then say well actually so what god
desires is mercy
and not more of that
not more
sacrifice
um
i i want to kind of get at this from
maybe coming at it from like an example
or a kind of imagine a kind of
imaginative scenario imagine that um
you are
a in some sense like a religious person
i don't mean that in a bad way um that's
often means in our modern culture like
you know i don't know
religious or something but i just mean
it in a good way like
you know you're let's say a christian
perhaps i don't presume everyone here
but probably many of you would
adopt that label or something like that
right so let's say you're christian
and let's say there was a season though
in your life
where
you were pick your metaphor stay away
from the purity ones you know um you
were on the wrong path you were
just not right you were sick you were
just like it was just a bad season a bad
season of life like you look back um
from many of us it was like our 20s you
know just like oh gosh maybe into the 30
you know whatever it was but it just
weren't in a good place um mixture of
bad decisions bad circumstances all kind
of swirling together
and
um
you were what's a good metaphor a hot
mess that's a good one like just you're
a hummus right um now through a number
of things
through
um maybe it was like church community
or therapy
or um times of worship or just you know
and through another maybe you attended a
meetup whatever it is but um god in his
grace kind of meets you and it's like
god's working you're making some
decisions it's coming together
and let's say it's not like you become
perfect but it's just better
you know and you get at least generally
on what we might call the right path or
what you feel is like okay yes i'm
better i'm off the bad path i'm on the
good path now let's say that plays out
over a few years
over time what you might find developing
is what we might call a certain passion
for holiness
a passion for purity
right purity of mind
purity of like living where in essence i
just mean you want to stay on the right
path right
um
and and then how does that play out what
you might find is that you you start
almost unconsciously at first
but you begin to
build walls
um metaphorically speaking right walls
between
um yourself
and certain
people in places
um
why
well because they're representative of
the
the wrong path
you know
and
you don't want to get pulled onto that
wrong path again
and so you find yourself over say a
period of decades getting really really
good at saying
no
in the sense of no
i will not go there
because
that's where the muck in the mire is
that's where whatever your language is
the the sin is the wrong is the bad path
no no no no i'm not going there right
and even you might even find yourself
saying no
um i i will not spend time with those
people or those kinds of people those
people who are on the wrong path
because i'm now on the right path i
really want to stay on the right path
and i'm just very worried that if i get
with them well then i'm going to be
pulled onto the wrong path
now can you can you see how over time
maybe it's even at first like super well
intentioned but could you see well and
imagine this imagine it plays out over
generations
so it's not even just you and your life
but then you like teach your children
to like stay on the right path and they
teach their children
stay on the right path stay off the
wrong path
and you can see where it goes right how
it starts to play out and stay away
from those people in those places and
then their children stay on the right
path stay away from the bad path stay
away from those people right can you can
you see where psychologically like this
starts to play itself
out
so
um
what beck sort of names
that a drive and a passion for what we
might call sacrifice
um
it really is about it's a drive and a
passion for holiness for purity
in the danger of it
is that it very easily hooks up with
disgust psychology
and
we become walled off from others
so when hosea says in jesus echoing him
says i desire
mercy
not
more sacrifices
not more sacrifice what what might he be
getting at
um
well if sacrifice and holiness and
purity has a tendency to build walls
then what might mercy be about
going beyond the walls
right i mean
just think of the life of jesus is that
not like that parable i just gave you
about this theoretical person i mean is
that not exactly the pharisees
and in many ways is that not exactly
churches
and who even we
are over time tempted to become and if
we don't it's really only by god's grace
what happens if we start to build these
walls
but what is
mercy
what is
love
what is compassion
we might say um
well let me sum it up like this mercy
extends a bridge of love across the
chasm that holiness
constructs
extends a bridge of love across
the chasm
across the gap across the walls
that we
put up
in other words one way to think of
like love really becoming love
is the moment love is called to do
precisely that
like to to bridge the gap
to cross the chasm
to go precisely where holiness and
purity
might be saying
warning warning warning
like no
and yet love has a tendency to kind of
call us
there
you might even say
that love becomes love the moment it
sort of costs us something
because this gap this chasm
is not only i think about just disgust
um
but it's also like costly it's sort of
like the um emotional
barriers
um practical barriers walls that we
build that we're just like no i just
want to stay here
i just want to stay in this place
because this is where i'm comfortable
and let me just kind of stay behind the
walls it's like i get it it's
predictable
i'm comfortable
i like the people here
this is
good and yet what does love and mercy
and compassion keep calling us to do it
just keeps calling us beyond
um i was imagining how this like
um
kind of plays out in a number of ways i
was thinking
of like um parenting
and uh
when is the love of a parent like most
on display with their child is it when
their like kiddo wins an award and
they're there for the picture like
we're winners yeah um no yeah i mean
that's nice it's good to be there for
your kid when they're getting the award
um but when is the love of a parent like
most on display
well to go back to our discussed
analogies
or language
imagine those moments like how about
it's 3am
and
your three-year-old
has just vomited
for the fifth time
that
night
and you're exhausted
and you're like
i really don't want to deal with this
but what does love call you to do
can you see where in a way love and
disgust
are often paired together
it's like
what what disgust
what um
what purity
what sanctity
would kind of have us
like hmm
that's your problem
you know it's like
that and and it's precisely that's
what love calls us
or when love calls us to move towards
them
or maybe it's when you're a teenager
it's like late and you're tired
and you just want to go to bed but they
need to process
and so you sit there and you listen
when you would much rather go to sleep
or maybe it's when uh back to discuss
that uh when that kid has overflowed
their diaper for the tenth time in two
days
and it's disgusting
and you're just done you're just done
or to reverse it how about the love of a
child to a parent
is it when they're like parent gives
them christmas presents and they're like
thanks
thanks mom
is that the moment and then it's like oh
that they really love you know no what
what it's probably something more like
when that parent
might even in some way
offend
or
um
hurt in some way
and the child is really tempted to just
throw up the wall like i am done with
you you're an idiot i don't want
anything to do with you this is over
right we can relate to this um
and yet what what is love what is mercy
what is compassion it's this
capacity to say okay okay
um what would love look like
for me now what might love call me to
now in this moment
um
i was even thinking just reflecting on
my own life because truth be told i have
a lot of people that
you know in the grand scheme of things
are easy to love
um because they love me back and you
know things like that
but um there have been
seasons where it's been hard i had um
a friend
and uh
he
i've spoken about him before he he's
moved so we don't get coffee anymore we
used to get coffee every week and he
suffers from some pretty debilitating
mental illness um and has since his teen
years
and um he has schizophrenia
and when he gets off his medication
um it's it's really challenging i
remember um bringing him to
family christmas
and
i mean in many ways it's a picture of
what the book unclean is all about
you know because he would go through
these seasons like where he wouldn't um
shower
because he just wasn't like aware
and but we had this i this ritual where
i would meet him at the dart station
each week so we could kind of meet
halfway
and um
when he was off his medication it was
the hygiene so he wouldn't wash his hair
and at times i remember him being just
covered with bed bug bites because of
the his living situation in dallas
and um he would laugh at inappropriate
times you know because he's kind of
hearing you know things um
and but we had this little ritual where
he would get off the dart
and when he was like 20 30 feet away i
would like put my arms out you know and
i would just be like bro you know just
this little moment
and uh and then he would put his arms
out and he kind of walked towards me and
he'd be like oh
you know just like the bear hug but
here's the thing i remember every single
week
that moment being a struggle for me
like i remember every single i was
cursed every single week
i was so tempted to go with the knuckles
like knuckles maybe just pointer you
know like just hey you i do i love you i
love you but just maybe 10 feet apart
you know
um
but but in that moment what was love
calling me to do
like
cross the chasm
love compassion mercy mercy extends a
bridge of love and so every week it just
be like
hey man
get in here and i remember the hair and
everything you know everything i
remember we would get i would take him
out there was a season two where he
would take him to church
um
and
my kids would always try to roll down
the windows i'm like just leave the
windows up he knows what you're doing
you know um but it was a beautiful
lesson in like learning to love
learning to love
and the truth is
um
he
like he loved me unconditionally
he was there for me he would check in on
me
and i think this is where it becomes
such a beautiful thing it's not ever one
way you think it's one way but it never
is
like in the end
people
offend people hurt
people are hard to love
and yet we're called to just
keep extending
that bridge of love across the chasm
that holiness
that sanctity
that propriety
that hygiene
that right living
that morality
constructs
so as we come to the table of the lord
tonight
as we take in the body of christ and the
bread the blood of christ and the wine
may it be a moment
where we remember
um the crossm or the chasm crossing
god
where we remember the god who even as
the scriptures say while we were still
messed up
and would pick your metaphor lost
sick
in that moment
christ saw us christ died for us
rose again to reconnect us
so that's the the
invitation um
and all our at times unloveliness to
find ourselves as beloved and i hope you
can do that as you um come forward
tonight
so
as i mentioned every week this is um an
open table and uh meaning if you're here
tonight and you would like to
participate
uh
no one is like asking you theological
questions or
making sure you're really saved you know
or whatever um it's just if you want to
come forward and participate and you
want to connect with christ
then you are
you're welcome to do that
so
um
let me invite you with this celtic
christian invitation
this is the table
not of the church
but of the lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more
so come
you who have much faith
and you who have little
you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
come
because it's the lord jesus himself who
invites you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
do
um
[Music]
do
hmm
[Music]
do
there
[Music]
do
we're going to close out with a song
that's called come tear down the walls
and i was thinking earlier about just
each one of us and how we kind of show
up with different stories and
backgrounds and
there's a sense in
like the message that brett just
shared with us where each of us um can
apply this song from a like you know am
i putting up walls between
me and others and
um
and where where could god help me break
those down and
extend the bridge of love like he was
talking about and
there's also kind of this sense in my
heart that a lot of us show up to spaces
like this and maybe without even
realizing it put up some walls just
because of pain from our past
in church settings or religious settings
or just with god in general where we
feel like maybe he has let us down or
abandoned us or maybe not said who
not been who we thought that he was
um
so
i'm just coming into this song this week
asking god
um to help me be vulnerable and and show
me the areas where i may be
um
protecting myself unnecessarily
um and missing out on
all that he is missing out on all the
ways that he wants to
love and
and be close to me
um
and so i just wanted to share that
tonight
um so that you guys could also be
thinking through like are there walls
are there
are there areas where it's not just me
and people that i'm protecting myself
but also maybe
um from god
so
um
caitlyn's gonna leave this one and her
guitar strap broke so
that's why she's suddenly sitting down
i'm gonna move out of the way so you
guys can see her a little bit better
but um you guys please sing this along
with us and and let's let's pray that
god would help us to break down some of
those walls
[Music]
you all are welcome to stand if you like
lord
i am trusting that you are a faithful
father and all that you have it
[Music]
your love's is no other
won't you come and break through to me
over and over and over again i am
bringing my heart to you with open hands
closer and closer you'll draw me in as
the depths of my heart lay before you
again
over and over and over
i am bringing my heart to you with open
hands
closer and closer you draw me in as the
depths of my heart
[Music]
is you deserve every piece of my heart
every piece in my heart every piece in
my heart
come and tear down the walls i built up
[Music]
cause you
deserve every piece of my heart every
piece of my heart every piece in my
heart
lord
i am trusting that you are a faithful
father and all that you have it
a is
giver who loves like no other won't you
come and break through to me over and
over and over again i am bringing my
heart to you with open hands closer and
closer you join me and as the deaths of
my heart lay before you again
and over and over again i am bringing my
heart to you with
openness closer and closer you're
drawing me in
lay before you again
[Music]
come and tear down the
cause you deserve every piece of my
heart every piece of my heart every
piece one more time
come and tear down the walls have built
up every
cause you
deserve every piece of my heart every
piece of my heart every piece of my
heart
[Music]
thank you guys so much for all the heart
and work that y'all put into this
amazing and beautiful music it's a gift
thank y'all
um again right after service we're gonna
have state of the table right at 6 15 so
please stick around for that if you want
to dive into some nitty-gritty fun
details and hear more about who we are
what we are what we stand for
and on that note i wanted to share just
a teeny story i promise i'll talk fast
um years ago my husband and i moved to a
brand new town that neither one of us
knew
and so we'd been looking online on
zillow trying to find like where are we
going to live and we found this little
place it was in our price range we're
like awesome
so the friends that you know kind of
helped get us there we showed them the
house and they're like oh
not that neighborhood you do not want to
live in that neighborhood and my husband
said then that's exactly where we're
going
so we moved into this rough neighborhood
now it's very gentrified and it's not a
rough neighborhood but at the time it
was
and i
have the
my husband is the greatest treasure in
my life and
it's really cool because he's brett's
brother and so the story that brett is
sharing comes like within their dna it's
who they are it's not just a story
you know to make this sermon look good
or connect points it's who they are and
it's who their mother and their father
raised them to be with constantly having
the outsiders in their home and living
with them and staying with them i have
heard story after story and
i just wanted to share from kind of a
more
inside perspective of who these men are
and who you are getting to know and hear
from and the people that they have
collectively pulled in to create this
church are people who are wired very
similarly to that
and it's real and and i think with love
like that
the real love that welcomes all and has
open arms to anyone
is um
going to change the world one person at
a time
and i think the ripple effect of that is
is god moving and
join us join us through meetup groups
which is like our small groups join us
by showing up here coming to the state
of the
table join us by giving financially
which i know might feel icky to hear
said but when you give financially it's
what puts fuel in the tank to move this
along so join us because
i assure you it this is real and and
it's good and these men
are good the heart of these people
are good you are good
and um just wanted to share that
and i'm gonna share a benediction
a blessing to send you out for your week
you can close your eyes open your hands
take another deep breath and release and
just receive this for your week ahead of
you
you are a child of god
this is true on your best day and it's
true on your worst day so as you go into
your week
ahead with its yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in between
go filled with the assurance that you
are loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted just as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts of
grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with
peace be with you have a wonderful week